i
españa recaudó a las víctimas del
terrorismo este jueves en todo el país
se llevaron a cabo minutos de silencio y
actos institucionales pero el homenaje
principal tuvo lugar en madrid 17 años
después del atentado de la estación de
atocha este acto tuvo lugar en los
jardines del palacio real presidido por
los reyes de españa y contó también con
la presencia del gobierno de españa'
altos representantes de la unión europea
y asociaciones de víctimas del
terrorismo tanto en españa como en el
resto de europa ya que este acto solemne
y emotivo pues se enmarcó en la
conmemoración del día europeo de las
víctimas del terrorismo fijada cada 11
de marzo cada año desde esta masacre
yihadista en la capital española en 2004
en el que murieron 193 personas
este atentado sigue siendo el más
mortífero de europa hasta la fecha
[Música]
francia conmemora por segundo año
consecutivo el día en memoria de las
víctimas del terrorismo con ceremonias
en varios lugares del país aquí en la
capital fue manuel marco el encargado de
presidir la ceremonia en el patio de
honor de los inválidos aunque no
pronunció discurso alguno luego se
encontró con michelle al catalán o el
dueño de una imprenta a las afueras de
la ciudad y quien fue tomado como rehén
por los hermanos o cuasi aquellos
hombres será que perpetraron el ataque
el semanario satírico salido en enero de
2015 y luego se atrincheraron en esta
imprenta antes de ser abatidos o por a
la policía para el elíseo era importante
que el presidente volviera a este lugar
tan lleno de historia y también de
símbolos el terrorismo continúa siendo
una de las amenazas más latentes sobre
la seguridad del país el gobierno espera
que con la recién aprobada ley contra
los separatismos pueda luchar de raíz
contra este problema en parte gracias a
la prohibición de ideologías por ejemplo
que vengan del islamismo radical y que
vayan en contra de los valores sobre los
cuales reposa la república francesa
[Música]
de marzo es el día europeo en memoria de
todas las víctimas del terrorismo porque
fue el 11 de marzo de 2004 en que se
perpetró un atentado por parte de al
qaeda en madrid en que asesinó a casi
200 personas y más de 2.000 personas
fueron heridas desde hace ya 15 años que
se conmemora este día en recuerdo a las
víctimas hay bastantes actos en todas
las instituciones europeas con minutos
de silencio y también discursos en
recuerdo a todas las víctimas por su
parte bélgica pronto también conmemorará
el quinto aniversario del peor atentado
de la historia del país fue el 22 de
marzo de 2016 en que 35 personas fueron
asesinadas y más de 200 fueron heridas
con bombas en el aeropuerto de bruselas
y también en el metro de la ciudad este
atentado se produjo poco después del
atentado de parís desde 2015 formado
ambos atentados por la misma célula
terrorista por personas que aseguraban
formar parte del autodenominado estado
islámico
[Música]